the Democrat seized control of the
Senate Catherine Cortez masto wins in
Nevada giving the Democratic party 50
seats and with the casting votes of the
vice president a majority in the chamber
Republican Adam lexette becomes yet
another trump-supported candidate to
lose
earlier the Democratic party won in the
state of Arizona where former astronaut
Mark Kelly defeated Republican Blake
Masters
I'm not surprised by the turnout I'm
incredibly pleased I turn up and I think
it's a reflection of a quality of our
candidates and they they're all running
on the same program
When anybody who wasn't running on what
we did it all stayed and it was sticking
with it so I feel good I'm looking
forward to the next couple years and to
clear loser in the midterm elections his
former president Donald Trump whose
endorsement of so many losing candidates
will call into question his outsized
influence in the Republican party that
mean we got a runoff another of his
choices Herschel Walker is likely to
face an uphill battle in a runoff
election in Georgia next month
the counting of votes is continuing in
the House of Representative elections
Republicans still hold a slight lead but
the Democrats have closed the Gap with
some surprising winds in the past 24
hours
but even if Republicans do take control
of the house it will be by the slimmest
of margins and with control of the
Senate President Biden will still have a
lot of leeway to press forward with his
legislative agenda
above all these midterm elections have
cemented his stature as a leader which
in turn will give him a greater degree
of control over his party Mike Hanna Al
Jazeera Washington